yunus et squeeze aujourd'hui c'est lors
de l'épreuve finale je sais pas faire de
peine figure avec mes doigts
effectivement vous dit tout ce que mes
oeuvres d'art sont des véritables
brouillon je rêve de devenir dessinateur
ok je veux que ce rêve se réalise bordel
aujourd'hui c'est lors de l'épreuve
finale à la fin de cette vidéo sera si
j'abandonne définitivement ma carrière
de dessinateur c'est parti je vous ai
demandé sur twitter de me donner des
objets ou des gens à décines et caetera
et je vais faire ça avec plaisir c'est
parti miley cyrus très simple je vais y
firent de lui déjà alors qu'elles
jugeront suis déjà fier de moi alors
j'ai juste fait ce à quoi on guettait le
premier dessin soyez indulgents avec moi
s'il vous plaît déjà j'ai oublié les
bras voilà bon c'est parce qu'on chauffe
finalement infligé pas ce qui s'est
passé j'ai tenté faire des orteils ça a
donné des véritables pénis et la place
des pieds soyez indulgents attendait
j'oubliais un détail quand même elle est
sur sarouels king ball hockey qui est en
fait
révélation la tête de depardieu aucun
détail sur ces [ __ ] de ce je vais
faire c'est de petites couettes la cas
dans le clip mais ça ne l'est plus des
antennes de fin des yeux d'escargots bon
dessin suivant fait un autoportrait
pitié non djombo ben voila j'ai la tête
toute ronde donc ça c'est assez sain il
ya un bon début ya du progrès par
rapport au dessin précédents mais c'est
pas parfait
personne ne juge ok je peux tout vous
expliquer déjà premier truc est où ton
blasé ce qui explique ses deux petites
filles même si c'est le film tête
d'otaries au final la principale erreur
ça a été les oreilles voilà on dirait
juste des glaces finalement des magnums
mais ces eaux dans l'ensemble c'est pas
si mal attendez on va demander à
l'intéressé miolles situe l'aiment
oh c'était pas du tout rajouté au
montage ok merci jumbo pour ta
participation à bientôt
vraiment merci beaucoup non dessine pas
tout simplement est pas mal voilà des
cinq chefs air [ __ ] merci une glace
kit werc donc toi tu fais des rêves
vraiment bizarre la nuit voilà ça c'est
le bâton de la glace qu'il faut bien
manger et en bonus je les fais un petit
string voilà
ça devient bizarre un oiseau celui de
twitter
alors là mon cas elle nous prêts à voir
le logo parfait de twitter pourrait
presque croire saint brais s'envole
s'envole vous a vu s'envoler voilà juste
des plumes un peu chelou mais ça passe
bien là vraiment qu'est ce que ça fait
là seul @ ce n'est pas une sous de la
pub que j'ai placé dans l'eau vous
rejoindrai pas tu veux moi sur twitter
bande de bras normes non pas une notice
de meubles ikea ou coup on voit la défie
mignon vous avez donc besoin de 22
planches b18 et 268 cloud à 3 pour
construire un bordel inutile
vous le mettez dans un coin de votre
chambre et votre mère vous engueuler rap
ce que ça sert à rien c'est moche
bon j'en fais une plus propre construire
une table tada vous avez donc besoin de
pied de table et de table étape numéro 2
mettre les pieds de la table dans la
table très compliqué vraiment étape
numéro 3 vous avez une [ __ ] de table
ikea qui s'appelle probablement gloss
baisse peut et sait pas tout c'est pas
tout petit bonus vous ceux qui ont
précommandé la table vous mettrez un
petit chose en plus dans le pack et boum
là t'as peut devenir un lama mon gars
put lama pour manger les miettes ou les
rays qui traînent sur la table tous il
détenait retrait des gages à des hommes
et il ya un concept hockey et d'ailleurs
je vais poser un brevet sur ce concept
on sait jamais ikea on sait pas trop une
girafe
alors ça vous avoue son corps ce patron
encore de gérardmer
ouais qu'est ce qui se passe c'est la
meilleure chirac pour des visions dessau
mode [ __ ] je vais l'accrocher là juste
là comme ça elle sera parfaite
vous en pensez quoi toi nager raf et ça
peut même devenir une guitare pour ceux
qui ont précommandé sa tournée bigot ça
tout est bientôt y avoir une exposition
d'art les oeuvres d'art qui ne sont pas
des oeuvres d'art de squeeze rondoudou
ça doit être facile pour toi quoi que ça
ne va dessine sahai level atteint est ce
qu'il ya une fleur sur la planète il ya
plus de pétales que la fourberie miles
sans accent la fourberie à travail sur
les couleurs qui doit être fait a
notamment entre autres parce que moi je
suis prof d'arts plastiques ok c'est ça
le high level c'est ça l'aja vous n'avez
plus un litchi qu'une fleur les bancs au
en deux trois coups de feutre boom un
nouveau pokémon hockey vrai qu'il a des
cuisses un peu partout sur visage et qui
s'est coiffé juste là les miens pot de
gel ici uniquement bon là c'est pas
fameux la scirocco dessus sur cette voie
va être calé à l'épreuve finale c'est
sûr allez on prend sur nous je vise haut
je pense que tu en es capable
voilà une allée comme sur le dessin ci
contre dans la perspective est un peu
chelou et le petit chemin l'herbe les
arbres et le blanc de la feuille a4 tain
c'est un échec là j'avais mon rêve
jamais vous tombez sinon moi j'suis pas
foutu des cyber doit [ __ ] faut que les
rageux faut qu'à ceux qui veulent briser
mon rêve
même mon majeur et nargue et fait un
clin d'oeil bitches
les jeunes se doit éclairage au hockey
iggy azalea images
j'aimerais faire une petite parenthèse
sur les détails de ce ténor le cul
[ __ ] merde quoi c'est pas l isi et
gazelec je dessine c'est des grosses
fesses bordel coup et s'y attendait et
si depardieu est partout messieurs dames
partout pas sur tout ce qui est rond et
gros surtout mais la lienne de alien
isolation bah voilà qui me plaît alors
déjà son crâne je vais te profil ok
voilà moi chaque fois que je le vois je
vois comme ça
un mec qui a une banane à la place de la
tête une tête à vos peurs on sait pas
trop ce qu'il veut et puis un coran
finalement on s'en fout qu'il soit gay
et de l'attention est attirée par cette
espèce de gros crâne dégueulasse un
poney unijambiste atteint 2 et bolat à
peu ce poney avoir ou pas de chance
déjà il est unijambiste et en plus il
chante ebola et en plus ce quiz il
dessine voilà il est vrai qu un manque
d'inspiration
voilà je savais pas comment montrer
qu'il a bola du coup j'ai marqué et bola
sur son corps comme ça au moins c'est
clair on sait qu il m aulas appareils
spatiaux zizi de cheval c'est bel et
bien une jambe
et puis là-bas je ferai ce qu'il s'est
passé voix illuminati attend des
missions de mai comme ça et qu'on fait
est là ce cheval unijambiste atteint des
mollahs est devenu à tire bouchon et ça
c'est un doigt cooper de qui appartenait
à quelqu'un décide un point je suis sûr
que c'est le maximum que tu peux faire
ok
ok qu'est ce qui se passe mon gars
qu'est ce qui se passe dessine un sapin
de noël
alors ça c'est ce qu'on fait à l'école
hockey normalement si mes souvenirs sont
bons on fait que ça maintenant mais
j'avais quand même quand j'étais petit
nom je crois que ça me reprend j'avais
un problème de centrage on a chaque fois
je me faisais avoir par la même connerie
je me souviens je faisais un sapin sauf
que voilà il y avait un côté qui était
carrément plus écartée du pied que de
l'autre la sapin il tombe par terre
normalement j'avais le même problème
quand j'étais petit mes souvenirs
douloureux qui peut rappeler je souffre
je souffre dessine aux yeux après avoir
vu un de tes dessins abba bien sûr vous
êtes comme ça tellement vous êtes
impressionné et même dans votre bouche y
a quelqu'un que vous ne connaissez pas
qui est impressionné il ya même votre
petit doigt qui a fusionné avec votre
pouce pour donner un média paus on dire
que vous méga aimé les dessins dessine
sa les jolies ce dessin un peu glauque
mais joli je prends le temps qu'il faut
me soulage le fait est pas parfait
qu'est ce qui se passe ça c'est moi ça
j'ai même fait avec des crayons de
couleurs un petit peu à l'eau et tous
ces mois c'est monde et ça c'est à moi
j'aime ça demandé beaucoup de travail
j'ai dû comme le fait en collaboration
avec ma [ __ ] d'imprimantes et
franchement c'est super bien réparti le
travail et tout ça un amour elle est
belle vous dit bonjour
non et voilà j'en sais dire français
vidéo j'espère que vous a plu et si
c'est le cas comme d'habitude n'hésitez
pas à aimer la vidéo si vous aimez ce
genre de vidéo spéciale c'est
aujourd'hui dans les commentaires que
vous allez me dire si j'ai réussi
l'épreuve finale ou pas je compte sur
vous j'espère vous avoir épaté je crois
pas trop je vous peut-être que là vous
avez bon coup cette est finalement
annoncée pas peut-être que ça va très
bien se passer pour moi cette épreuve
finale merci d'avoir regardé en sortant
de chez lui dans une nouvelle vidéo
tient tout le monde puisse plus mal au
crâne super bowl en conneries de
morceaux de métal là
[Musique]